[Музика]
yummo of choose Суддя був Doge
iam Isaiah Watsuhita, якщо до алергії
Nomura, де залишили найактивніший фільм Ф.К.
Пікассо, я просто хочу кулею Раджу
Костецького, бараку, потужності
каже Чака, місцевість того походження, що
з глечика  fragile is komova знизу вгору
Ерік давай запустимо мотор синій багато дошки
Шекхар був обраний в окремому
параграфі відхилено атаку ми маємо до
того, що це приквел, помирає
найменше, Альберт
[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, настав час уроків англійської,
мене звати  Наталія, давайте почнемо,
і я хотів би привітати моїх дорогих
гостей, Лі, привіт, Дженна,
як ти, я фантастична ідеальна, і
ти знаєш, що з тобою, як справи, я в
порядку, дякую
добре, тому, коли я почну урок, так
сьогодні  ми будемо говорити про телешоу,
щоб вам було легко, вам подобається
ця тема, тож давайте розважимось, і
сьогодні ми розпочнемо з домашнього завдання. Я попросив своїх
учнів вивчити типи фільмів,
тож давайте подивимося, що ми
виявили  У нас є історичний фільм
пригодницький фільм жахів наукова фантастика
та комедія чи знаєте ви всі ці слова
так, так, добре,
і це визначення, тому допоможіть мені
здогадатися, так що фільм, який змушує людей сміятися
так, Джина комедія так Браво, так що один бал
для Джини, дякую добре  захоплюючий фільм
з великою кількістю екшену багато речей
відбувається пригоди так виправити
страшний фільм або страшно страшно
страшно це жах Кора Браво
добре і фільм про майбутнє чи життя
в космосі це наукова фантастика Браво
дивись так геній на першому місці, будь ласка, приходьте
прокинься фільм, де хтось намагається
розкрити кримінальну наукову фантастику. Ні фантастика
не про космос, це детектив
так, це детектив, відомий
детектив має Крістіан,
добре, так, Шерлок Холмс, і так, ми любимо
всі ці фільми, і останній фільм
про події, що відбувалися в минулому
в минулому в історичних фільмах
Орегона так чи знаєте ви якісь історичні фільми 30
спартанців так
так, як гладіатори ROI як Queen
Vict  oria роки так багато фільмів добре,
давайте йти далі, тому, коли ми говоримо про
фільми, ми описуємо їх за допомогою прикметників
давайте подивимося на перший прикметник,
тому фільм цікавий, чи можете ви
повторити за мною цікаво цікаво
цікаво цікаво це цікаво
наступний  один що ти думаєш добре, і ми
говорили про прикметники для
опису бразильця так, це сумно або
депресивно, депресивно
так, це дуже легко запам'ятати
через слово депресія так, у нас така
сама депресія, депресія або депресія,
і це сумно, що це можливо, ви
не потрібно використовувати обидва ви вибираєте це
сумно давайте повторимо це гнітюче
це пригнічує добре наступний
сміється так ми багато сміємося і
прикметник так це смішно, тому ми любимо
Господа, і вам слід бути обережними з цим
словом  коли ви кажете, що це весело, весело, це означає,
що це цікаво, було так весело
, було цікаво, було добре,
вам сподобалося, це було дуже позитивно,
але коли ви кажете смішно, це означає  що
ситуація була смішною, добре, тому люди
сміялися, і це іноді також може бути негативним
, тому будьте обережні
, можете сказати, що це весело, о, це смішно,
добре, добре,
давайте повідомимо один, це смішно, але це ще
більше, це веселіше, це як так, я"  Я
допоможу вам, не хвилюйтеся, це нові
слова для вас, добре, тому ми говоримо
захоплююче мистецтво
або дивовижне так, наприклад, ви бачили
фільм, ви дивилися фільм, це настільки
цікаво, вам подобається, і ви говорите, що
це захоплююче дивовижно, дивіться так  Ви
також можете використовувати ці прикметники для опису
людей або подій, наприклад, шоу
було таким захоплюючим або дивовижним, а
іноді, наприклад, ви збираєтеся в
подорож, і ви не можете чекати, у вас ніби у вас
є метелики, як у мене
десь, щоб ти міг сказати, що я цікавий,
наступний
ах, це зовсім нецікаво, це
нудно, о, хлопчик, так, це нудно,
так це для тебе так, так, нудно, нудно
, скажімо разом, це нудно, це
нудно, і ти добре знаєш, так що нудний лід
і  останній фільм жахів як  чи можемо ми
описати це страшно так ах налякано
страшно можливо або лякаюче правильно
насолоджувалось страшно давайте повторимо ще раз
лякаюче це страшно
це правильно Браво добре, вибачте, ми
будемо використовувати ці прикметники в діалозі
послухайте мене, вам подобаються історичні
фільми так, я люблю їх так  Я вони
мм-хм, що ми можемо використати тут ні це
цікаво добре дуже цікаво, давайте
перейдемо до другої частини, а як щодо фільмів жахів, вони
мені не подобаються,
вони також страшні, страшні чи можливі, тому тут
ми використаємо цікаві та лякаючі
добре, добре, тож давайте зосередимося на цьому
діалозі, я маю запитати вас, чи є у вас
невідомі слова, чи знаєте ви всі слова
ні, ні, дозвольте мені допомогти вам ні
я, ні я, ні я, так що
подивіться на це, ви кажете так  Я люблю їх, і
ти хочеш підтвердити, що тобі це подобається, і я
люблю це, тому я кажу так, я так - Лу
Блум, так і я, але якщо тобі щось не подобається,
що мені це не подобається, ти скажеш, що
ні я, чи ні  Я так і роблю,
щоб підтвердити, що ви лі  ке, і
я також не маю, що ти робиш так - Майло Белло
добре, ти знаєш, щоб не повторювати, мені це також не подобається
, ти просто кажеш добре будь-які інші
слова добре, тому щоб запам'ятати
діалог, нам потрібно вимовляти його багато
разів
добре  тож ми збираємося повторити
діалог, який ти повторюєш за мною або говоримо
зі мною, і в якийсь момент деякі слова
зникнуть
Слава Будлес Некаті, але нам потрібно продовжувати
говорити, тому намагайся запам'ятати добре, я
покажу тобі ось так о,
без слів ха-ха  так що спробуй згадати, давайте
підемо один два три ми говоримо разом добре
добре так добре зараз Дженна тільки ти
любиш історичні фільми Браво
так я так люблю я тобі подобаються історичні
фільми так я люблю їх
що так мені цікаво як
щодо фільмів жахів я  я їх
теж не люблю
чи вони налякані
пт  востаннє страшно страшно добре
і востаннє разом знову п'ятниця
п'ятниця дивовижно вмієш це зробити, але я не
думаю, що
ви були чудовими студентами, дуже дякую вам,
тож давайте створимо ваш діалог,
щоб Дженна поговорила з
балліною, скажи  тобі подобається ти запитуєш свій
фільм ти можеш сказати чи любиш комедії чи
фільми жахів чи детективи добре
щовечора ти відповідаєш так, мені подобається добре,
а потім підтверджуєш, що тобі
подобається, і даєш прикметник
цікавий смішний страшний це залежить від
фільм про те, що цивільне - це країна, використовуйте
добре, так що якщо ви скажете, що я люблю комедії,
добре, ви любите детективи так, я
люблю їх, закрийте очі там
цікаво добре, як щовечора і як
щодо фільмів жахів добре, я їх не люблю
, але це  неправда
[Сміх] також
не я, вони страшні так Браво
добре, тепер твоя
черга придумай свій власний діалект, і я
збираюся перевірити це наступного разу, добре,
і ми продовжуємо сьогодні, ми поговоримо, почніть
говорити про телешоу, тож нехай  '  ходити з
різними телешоу у мене є фотографії добре,
так що ти думаєш, що це номер один це
що ти думаєш це ти можеш
описати ти можеш сказати це українською
так, але я, але ти можеш показати талант
ти знаєш, що це як Вікторина дон
Ви не отримуєте відповіді, добре,
наступний, хто вижив, це реаліті-
шоу,
так, а останнє, так, яке
шоу, я допоможу вам, тому, перш
за все, це ігрове шоу або вікторина,
запитання вікторини так, гра  шоу
можливо реаліті-шоу вона мала рацію,
тому ми спілкуємося ми говоримо
це можливо для вашого шоу
Я думаю, ток-шоу більш популярне правильно
[Музика]
ток-шоу більш популярне Я не впевнений,
що чат-шоу можна сказати  але
ток-шоу популярніше, добре, тому
ще раз вікторина-шоу вікторина реаліті-шоу реаліті-
шоу реаліті-шоу і ча-ча-ча-ча О,
ток-шоу, ток-шоу Браво,
давайте йти далі з програмами, щоб прогрес
міг бути різними програмами добре, це
програми на телебаченні
так програми на телебаченні  ах ви можете вгадати будь-яку
спортивну програму  це схоже на відкриття,
як і будь-що інше, можливо, відчуваю, що можна відчути
вид плівки, дозвольте мені допомогти вам,
тому програма «Зроби сам» це «зроби сам»
Програма «Зроби сам» або «Зроби сам» або «Зроби сам» так,
наступна програма «Природа» програма «Природа
», це не тільки про тварин, це
все разом, це моя природа так, так,
правильно музична програма музична програма добре
будь-які приклади музичної програми Я знаю,
яка типова музика каналу називається
музика  канал, тому там є лише музичні
програми так так так точно ви
можете сказати добре, давайте перейдемо до спортивних
програм спортивна програма людина садівнича
програма це про ці дані так,
дуже дякую,
все добре, ні, дякую, це було моє
запитання, яке я попросив вас дати
приклади телевізійних шоу, а потім кулінарних програм, у
нас є їх багато правильного, що вам
подобається, і у нас є інші програми,
які не є шоу, не програмовані, а не
програми, тож давайте  Подивіться,
наприклад, що програма, що це
це за мультфільм, будь-який запах, наприклад, як
залишиться Санта-Барбара добре вид
зернових так, добре, будь-який, тому у нас є фільми,
дозвольте мені допомогти вам, перший з них -
ситком, так, у нас є сцена та
люди сміються на задньому плані,
ви їх чуєте, тому це ситком наступний
це драма так багато людей люблять драми,
вони можуть плакати і підтримувати
героїв драматичних програм наступний
документальний фільм це мильна опера
так стійкість президент APPA так  ми
їх дуже любимо знімаємо багато фільмів добре
тоді використовуйте це дуже важливо
використовувати статтю, а потім використовувати новини та
мультфільми
добре, тому давайте переглянемо ще раз, щоб шоу могло
бути грою, яку ви пам'ятаєте, гра та вікторина
це те саме і  спілкуйся та розмовляй
це ті самі програми так і інші
люблять мультфільми ситкому так знову що
твій улюблений що ти віддаєш перевагу
дивитися ситком чи фільм ситком чи
фільм добре а ти
знімаєш у мультфільмах мультфільми добре що
про кулінарні шоу іноді час
від часу я люблю готувати і я люблю
дивитися кулінарні шоу, це моє
улюблене, тому давайте йти далі, зараз ми
збираємося грати в гру, так що це
знову у нас є собака, як його звати,
дайте йому  назвіть синяка
добре, тому Дрю Джоку потрібно повернутися додому, його
немає вдома, він у лісі, і він
мав повернутися додому, це його дім мм-хм,
добре, мій малюнок не такий хороший, я
ілюзія,
тому є кілька сходів для  жарт, щоб
піти додому, я покажу тобі картинку, тож
це перше зображення, яке тобі потрібно
відгадати, але ти не можеш назвати його
відразу, ти повинен дати мені
букви подивіться один два три чотири це
перші слова вісім  літери, які ви не можете назвати
, ви не можете сказати мені по-італійськи, ви даєте
мені літери libera NOS vies і коли
буква правильна,
Драгіч падає, коли літера
неправильна,
Драгіч повертається до лісу, тому що
вона неправильна, тому ви подивіться на
малюнок ти згадаєш, що це таке, і
дай мені листи, почнемо  швейцарські жінки,
добре, добре, дайте мені, як s CC, так що si si SS
коза є s і через роботу йде на
спад добре,
ви продовжуєте, тому що вона стає добре зачекайте
добре о, добре,
фантастично, давайте спробуємо Дженні добре,
Дженні, я чую правильно, і робота йде
вниз ма дозвольте запитати вас так ви добре
що ww вибачте ні w тут w ah вибачте
Деніел о це цікаво
о так я зробив помилку так привіт вчителю
мій боже вибачте,
тому я зробив повороти для вас, а потім ще
один окей, вибачте,
це не буде  вибачте, вибачте,
продовжуйте
подивитись, що це, це саме те, що
це правильно, добре, це
ви добре, і останній
дивовижний жарт про ембріон одного віку
.
починай,
так, так, а тут Браво, так справжня робота
падає більше о проклятий шериф
Америка о, противно,
добре, добре,
фантастично Гей
так Гей
так супі мм-хм
Браво
і II і так, і названий Ріццо cos
вдома і назва фільму
так  мильна опера да добре і ле  Спробуймо
ще раз,
давайте помремо сумний Ріццо повертається до
лісу, давайте допоможемо йому побачити фантастику Гей,
молодці, добре, чай, гарний, о
дабл-о-дабл,
о, і Браво та Yahoo, тож я думаю, що
наступний буде для Генджі, добре
так це для вас,
це друзі один два три чотири п'ять
шість
ви можете утриматися так, тримати на
овоч запитайте о, тримайтеся ах так
добре бачу добре так я так о так так
фантастично
це було дивовижно, тому скеля знову щаслива
тепер він просить кістку, фантастичне
дякую, і останнє
для моїх студентів, які намагаються зрозуміти, що
це, і я питаю вас зараз, чи можете ви вгадати, що
шоу дасть їм правильну відповідь так,
це ток-шоу або чат-шоу, давайте
рухайтеся далі, щоб у нас була телепрограма та у нас
є список усіх можливих програм,
але у нас є лише п’ять, які нам потрібно
закінчити, тому подивіться о 18:00
ввечері у нас зі стандартами,
що це за
кулінарна програма, добре, я дам вам
допомогу, це просто назва так, добре, так що
захід і це може бути сер, так може бути
мильна опера. О, може бути мильна опера або
документальний фільм  добре,
неможливо добре, давайте перевіримо пізніше,
тому о 6:30 канал номер один
має талант, тому це
реаліті-шоу номер три
, подивіться, другий канал, чи можете ви вгадати,
що це за шоу, якщо ви собака, то
якщо ви  не можете ви вгадати чи можете ви здогадатися,
це вікторина, шоу, вікторина, шоу, брова о, гей,
ігрове шоу так
[Сміх]
HBM матч дня Sports Show спортивна
програма програма гарна
і номер п'ять 7:30 лише 6500 грам так,
давайте перевіримо музику спортивної програми
програма вікторини, яка має талант,
це реаліті-шоу, а це
західна мильна опера.
опери так добре я маю на увазі робити
у нас є до так добре мультфільми Томас
так Nickelodeon canola так добре добре,
як щодо реаліті-шоу, ми поставили якусь дитину
на Янкі, але у нас є те саме, у кого
є таланти, танцювальні шоу, правильно, у
нас є багато шоу, добре, тому тепер
слухайте я  я збираюся читати вам текст
про Пем Пем опишемо шість
шоу ситкоми реаліті-шоу вікторини шоу
мильні опери фільми спортивна програма, яка їй
подобається щось, що їй не подобається або
щось ненавидить, не заперечувати означає, що
все добре, я можу дивитися  це, але мені не
подобається ця справа  день на
півгодини мені також подобаються ситкоми, тому я
ніколи не пропускаю друзів по п'ятницях у
будні дні я зазвичай дивлюся фільм або
спортивну програму, вони добре, якщо у вас немає
нічого кращого, крім дійсно
постійних реаліті-шоу та вікторини,
вони
дійсно нудно, і я ніколи не дивлюся  h,
допоможіть мені, це текст для вас, щоб ви
могли подивитися, допоможіть мені, які часи, як не
подобається, о, це добре для неї, це так, ніби
це мильна опера, добре, що ще
подивіться на теги,
це серіали, добре, ви можете я  зазвичай мийте
свої фільми або спортивну програму на багато
розуму Спорт, так що немає клієнтів фільми,
вони нічого кращого для балету О,
Крістен дійсно показує, що AHA ненавиджу, це
справжні реаліті-шоу та вікторини. Браво,
давайте перевіримо, так що ситком мильна опера добре
зроблений фільм  спортивні програми хороші та
реаліті-шоу, вікторини, зараз немає часу.
Я попрошу вас подивитись і
спам, і мені подобаються BAM, як ситкоми та
Auburn, тому я можу сказати, чи мені подобаються ситкоми
в мильних операх, я кажу і бамбу, і мені
подобається  так Патрас так, у моєму житті БАМ любить
ситкоми, але я не
віддаю перевагу спортивним програмам, наприклад, Пем
не проти фільмів, але мені подобаються реаліті-
шоу, наприклад, ані Пем, ні, я люблю
реаліті-шоу, тому що ми обом їх не любимо
, тож давайте  спробуйте пару
речень ми починаємо з Авеліни
добре  будь ласка, і Пем, і мені подобаються ситкоми,
хороші Пем любить хороші фільми, але я не
віддаю перевагу шоу Квінз Пем не проти
пройти вікторину, але мені подобаються мильні
опери Браво
Анісса Памела ні, мені подобаються
реальні реаліті-шоу Браво,
добре, справді, ти можеш спробувати  добре, ходімо,
давайте спробуємо і Пем, і я люблю ситкоми
добре
Пем любить мильні опери, але я не
віддаю перевагу спортивним програмам Пем не проти
фільмів, але мені подобається шоу добре
біля Пем ні, мені подобається реаліті-шоу
Браво,
це було добре, дякую  тобі дуже, зараз
настав час для домашнього завдання, тож напиши
речення про те, що ти робиш чи не
любиш дивитися, використовуй приклад
я люблю дивитися вікторини я терпіти не можу
документальні фільми наприклад я ніколи не
дивився спортивні програми вони нудні,
на жаль, є  дзвіночок, і
нам потрібно припинити урок добре
дякую дуже за урок
дякую до побачення мій новий чоловік використовує Падую менше
грошей це було неминуче на
шоу лазаньї мама дивитися гарного хлопчика Шанта
тут Kadri poha день ось що може  Я
розумію тебе  ua nice kimono me where she lives
радянська суб-коала tog актуалізованого Pocasset
я б сказав X Aras плаче, якщо ви вимір,
коли скелястий просто nope вона не яхта
була готова просунутися до muchas TSP пристроїв
у моєму садовому котеджі Buddha a досить не
балакучий онлайн
[Музика]
ти